hi
my name is ashley jacoby and i am a
scientist
in the research and development group at
integrated technologies
today i'm excited to present some of the
new work our team has done in the crispr
space
specifically focusing on some regions
that we've developed to enhance
crispr efficiency and specificity and
then to showcase
a new crispr analysis
pipeline that we've developed that we um
hope to release out to um
the community soon
so in our r d group we've really focused
over the last
five years to develop innovative
solutions
for the full crispr workflow starting
with
the design of our reagents all the way
through to
analysis and today i'm really going to
focus
on the things i have highlighted in
orange which are some of the newer
things that we've developed
over the last year um but to kind of
highlight everything
um we have an incredible bioinformatics
team that works very closely with our
what bench scientists
so we have taken empirical data and
developed and
crispr cast 9 guide rna design tool
um we also earlier this year
launched an hdr design tool which has a
nice
user interface and integrates with our
guide rna
design tool providing rule sets to
develop
help you develop your hdr substrate
and then we also have a
our ramp seek design tool which will
help you design
primers for ngs analysis and then
in our cast in our reagents category
we've done a lot of work
focusing on guide rna development and
protein development and i'll highlight
some of those
today as well for hdr
reagents um we've got short
all modified single stranded oligos
as well as longer fragments and we're
working on a new
technology where we're modifying double
stranded fragments to get you
on a little bit longer material and
we've been doing a lot of work with
small molecules to
study those and see what of those will
help boost hdr rates
and lastly we've really put a lot of
effort into
optimizing our ramps seek system for
crispr and this is an ngs multiplex
amplicon sequencing technology that'll
spend a bit of time talking and linking
that now to
um an internally developed ngs analysis
tool that
we are hoping to provide through a
cloud-hosted environment um
next year so jumping
on into some new developments with guide
rnas
um our team has spent a lot of time
optimizing the length and the
modification patterns
for both a two part and a single guide
rna
forecast nine as well as the crna for
cast vulva
we've done a lot of this work in r d
studying the length and modification
patterns but we've also done a lot of
optimization
in our manufacturing group to make sure
we are
able to synthesize the highest quality
material and keep pushing the
the links that we're able to make
and since we are able to make these uh
synthetic
guide rnas in high throughput we are
able to provide a lot of customizability
to
researchers doing genomic screens
knockout loss of function assays and so
we
we can provide crispr libraries
by tens of thousands of guide rnas and
we do have some stocked options
where we've got whole genome library
human kinase library and
human epigenetics library ready to order
as our two-part system but we also
do a lot of custom library synthesis for
our customers that can be done
in two-part or single guide rna as
pooled or raid format and this
takes into account our can you utilize
our
idt derived design algorithm
um that we've that i mentioned has come
off empirically defined data
to help predict the the best quality
guide rnas
or we can take custom designs into
effect too
and so highlighting some data we've
generated internally
for crispr screens using different guide
rnas
in this case this is just a a small
experiment here shown
where we've looked at four guide rnas
in five different genes synthesized as
either a two part guide rna for cast
nine
or a single guide rna and what this
figure is showing
in the in the top panel is the two part
guide rnas
and the bottom is the single guide rnas
and we've delivered these
via electroporation into half one cells
at two different doses as rnp complexes
and so the green is going to be the
higher dose and the blue is the lower
dose
where the the line is the average
what we're seeing and what we really see
here is that at the higher dose for
at all of these genes for both the two
part or the single guide rna we're
getting greater than 85 percent
efficiency at every loci we're looking
at and this is in in hap1 cells here so
you know our algorithm is predicting
very high
efficient guide rnas and we're able to
to deliver these and
create really high levels of editing
another thing i wanted to just touch on
as
as the crispr system is expanding and
new nuclear systems are being discovered
we wanted to
make sure we make it easier for
researchers to be able to to get rnas of
any length so
um soon we'll be able to have we'll have
a custom guide rna ordering tool that
will allow you to order
guide rnas from 30 to 150 nucleotides
right off our website
um supporting chemical modifications and
this will allow you to
to study these novel systems and be able
to
have a really easy way to order these
and and get you
guide rnas um that are very customizable
to to your experiment
and so likewise in our r d
group the the great new technology that
um was published last year out of the
loot lab prime editing
um we wanted to study this using
chemically synthesized peg rnas at idt
and so prime editing functions through
genome editing without a double-stranded
break nor the need for a separate
uh donor dna template so what the what
the prime editing
construct is is a fusion protein of cas9
h840a nickase and an mlmlv reverse
transcriptase
that then associates with a long guide
rna
known as a peg rna so that has shown um
the peg rna is shown here
in the blue green and orange uh
schematic
and and so this ends up being a
in the range of 120 and greater um
length rna which is composed of the
targeting and rna region
which is that lower dark blue
region and then the enzyme binding
region in green
and then a region that has the prime
primer binding site
and the edited the a region where you
want
to make your corrective material
so what we've done here is we wanted to
study if we could
how chemical modifications in the peg
rna
would tolerate to prime editing
so what we have done here is we are
inserting that ctt
sequence at site heck three and we have
we are using either unmodified peg rna
or a chemically modified peg rna and the
sequence for this is shown in the bottom
where we put
three three two primal methyl bases and
three phosphorous thy weight linkages
on each end of this 122 nucleotide rna
oligo
we've electrocuted this into k562 cells
along with the pe2 plasmid and
co-delivered this and what you can see
here
in orange is that there's no insertion
of that ctt
um assessed via ngs when we've used an
unmodified
peg rna however when we use a peg rna
that is chemically modified
in the blue color we are seeing high
levels of
insertion very comparative to um
just delivering this all as a plasmid
construct
and as a proof of concept we have also
um purified this pe2 construct
as recombinant protein and we have
complexed this to the
modified peg rna and delivered this with
or without
our altar cas9 electroporation enhancer
into your cat cells
and we do see successful prime editing
in a dose response here
um by using a delivering this as a
ribonuclear protein complex
so to kind of now focus a little more on
on the crisper protein engineering
updates that
um we've done um our r d
team really has focused over the last
couple years on and two main things in
our in our protein engineering
r d group the main the first uh point is
to
improve fundamental shortcomings of of
the popular crispr enzymes
the the main one being uh cas9 from
strep pyogenes and
the um the main identified problem with
that is that the editing is not perfect
and we can have some off-target editing
so we have um through bacteromutogenesis
evolved a high fidelity cas9
and then as cast 12a or lb cast 12a the
um
main shortcoming of that protein was
just the
lower on target editing scene when this
was delivered as a rnp complex so we
also did a spectrum neogenesis screen to
evolve an enhanced activity version
um some other things we've been working
on lately is to
develop new crispr enzyme formats to
basically broaden the utility so
creating some fluorescent fusion
proteins where
gfp or m cherry are tagged to the
protein
and then creating some enzymes that are
in alternative buffers so specifically a
glycerol-free storage buffer
which functions as well as our our
standard 50 glycerol storage but it's um
amenable to liquid handling and in some
cases we've seen um higher performance
and then it could be a single component
component storage reagent as well
just so so to highlight some some data
from
um each of those um proteins that we've
developed
um the uh a couple years ago a
big focus was on developing the the high
fidelity cast nine
and this was published in nature
medicine
and briefly what was done here was
through a low fidelity pcr creating a
bacterial mutagenesis
library where we set up a two plasmid
system
where the mutants we were screening had
to
cleave the on target site and not cleave
an off target site to survive
so doing that screen taking the mutants
that survived that and purifying those
and then actually studying those in the
context of an rnp delivery
and seeing which one ultimately
maintained on target activity while
reducing off target activity
and what we've settled on is what we
refer to as the altar hi-fi cas9
and just a a one-figure summary of this
is shown
here on the right where um you know in a
worst-case scenario where you're working
in an expressed
system um what this figure on the left
is depicting
is in orange the total
editing we're seeing at the on target
site
and then every blue bar is editing we're
seeing at off target sites so if you
take all that
total reads together from that the
population actually has only 28
of on target editing where the remainder
of what we're detecting is all different
levels of off target
so then switching and using a high
fidelity cast
using our high fidelity cast 9 we're
able to maintain high levels of
on target activity and and
almost reduce all of that off target
editing and this is in a guide
that is has very high levels of
off-target editing
and further what's shown in that
manuscript is that this high fidelity
cast 9 is able
to provide robust sickle cell gene
correction
so in that top panel a we're able to
show
maintained activity of the hificast nine
when delivering an a delivering
alongside an aav6
construct and then in panel b the uh
ontario or the um off target levels you
can see
there that off target one has thirty
percent
level of editing with the wild type and
we're able to reduce that
um with the hificast nine
and additionally i wanted to point out
that the hificast nine is available
um as a gmp protein uh off the shelf
through aldebaran
um trademarked as spyfycas9
and so moving on to the other uh
directed evolution project
that we have done is through for as cash
12a and in a similar manner
where in this case we are wanting to
identify a
construct that had higher activity so we
we set up this system
to find a construct that could cleave a
quadruple t
which is the pam site that is least
active
in cast 12a and what we've settled on
is our a.s 12i ultra
mutant that now has superior editing
levels over the wild type cast 9
and that's depicted here in this figure
where we've looked at
71 different sites and what's shown in
this box and whisker plot
on the left in heck 293 cells we're
comparing
the wild type cast 12a protein and
complex to the guide rna delivered as
rnp
the 71 sites you can see the average
editing
um of all of those sites is under 40
however
now with our ultra we're near 100
editing
additionally as i mentioned um we're
work very closely with our
bioinformatics team so now we are you
know going even further now to
try and design an algorithm to to
isolate out any of those low performing
sites but you can see by just
random selection of guide rnas we are
getting very high levels of editing now
with this ultra
and then the second side of this graph
is showing
in your cat cells um comparing
this now to cast 9 and looking at guide
rnas and similar
genomic regions where we're able to now
see editing levels that are very compare
comparable to cast nine um using cast 12
by ultra
and a serendipitous finding we found
with
our our ultra mutants for both um a s
and
lb is that they actually have increased
temper temperature tolerance
so here we're delivering rnp complexes
into cells and then incubating them at
either 30 degrees celsius or 37 degrees
celsius
and in a dose response you can see
that at 30 degrees the ultra
variants have much higher activity
than the wild type and are much more
tolerable to these lower temperatures
as i mentioned we've also recently
developed a
uh glycerol free storage buffer that
maintains
activity um of our both our cast 9 and
cast 12 a
suite of proteins and so here we're
showing some data where
we have delivered about a dozen
different guide rnas
into heck 293 cells via electroporation
where the protein is in our standard 50
glycerol buffer
or now in a glycerol free buffer and
we've delivered these at two different
doses
so on the left we're showing the
individual
data points individual guide rna sites
in in blue and orange is at the high
dose and the other two colors are at
a low dose and what we're seeing here
which is um shown probably a little more
clearly to in the right figure in the
box and whisker is that
the glycerol free at both doses
has equal activity if not a little
higher so
um we're able to maintain that activity
now storing this in a glycerol free
buffer
um and then the the last protein
that i'd like to highlight today is
working on
developing fusion proteins where cas9
is fused to gfp or an m cherry to allow
for visualization of your delivery so
here in
in the bottom panel we're able to see um
we're able to image the gfp in our
heck 293 cells where we've delivered
this rnp complex
and now taking doing some facts
and looking at enrichment of editing
from using this
we've done this for both nuclear
affection and life affection
and what we've done here is we are
looking at the editing levels of the
unsorted population of cells
or population of cells where we've taken
the top 20
of the gx gfp expressing population
and what you can see in the bar graph is
that especially for lipofection
we are seeing a nice boost in total
editing
when i'm measuring the editing levels of
the the top 20 percent that we've been
able to sort out from that gfp
protein um nuclear affection you can see
a slight boost as well but um
we've we've seen that nuclear infection
is
so efficient already and you can kind of
see that in the um
the liposuction have a having a broader
distribution in that facts plot
but um using this does really enrich the
editing levels especially when you are
um
delivering via life affection
and then to show that we aren't seeing
any loss in activity
from these fluorescent proteins this bar
graph shows here
in the top panel for cast 9
the blue bar being wild type so your
baseline
delivering these as rnp into heck 293
cells
and then the other two bars showing the
level of editing when
the cast 9 is fused to gfp or m chair
you can see is
very similar levels of editing and the
same sort of thing on the
bottom panel where we've done this for
cast 12a comparing our cast 12a ultra
unlabeled protein to now our
fluorescently labeled gfp protein
very similar levels of total editing
and since we're discussing fluorescent
reagents here i did want to
mention our we also if you don't want to
label the protein
we can also label the uh the trace rna
if you're working in a two-part system
and so we've got these reagents um where
we've
um found putting a five prime
floor for on the tracer rna so that's
shown in the schematic off to the right
you can see that
that kind of red firecracker looking
image is where the floor floor
goes and so we've done this with
um three different dies here we've got
an ato 48
an ato 550 and an ato 647 and you can
see um
in the fat spots how we're able to um
isolate out those populations that have
that
fluorescent tag on the trace rna
and then doing a similar similar sort of
thing that i just showed
with the the protein and
we are now able to when delivered with
lipofection
we are here comparing at two different
guide rna sites
the unsorted population and that set of
four bars the
fourth bar on on the right of the set of
four
is unsorted and then if we take the um
the lower percentage of of the
particular wavelength we're looking at
the medium percentage so the
60 to 80 or the top 20 percent
we're able to show enrichment of editing
and
for all again we've shown here the gfp
protein again as the first
set of four and then the next three sets
are looking at the
three different trace rnas so you can
see for
one site on the left that three two
three one site and another
genomic loci on the right that we're
able to get enriched
levels of editing using these
fluorescent either protein or tracer rna
when we've delivered the rnp complex in
this case with a
rna imax
next i wanted to highlight some of the
improved solutions that we've
um done for hdr
um la we the last couple years
have been working on studying different
small molecule compounds
to add into your tissue culture media
um after delivering your um
electroporating your components into
your cells and then incubating
that in media that contains these hdr
enhancers
so we have what we refer to as our hdr
enhancer
v1 which if you compare that to
the gray bar which is a control here
we're looking at
hdr rates where we've made us a small
change a six base insertion
and then measure that perfect hdr by ngs
and so the gray bars shows the
hdr levels we get from just a control
and then if we add in that hdr enhancer
v1 in blue
you can see the boost we're getting in
four different cell types for both cast
nine and cast 12a
and we've now recently discovered a
another hdr enhancer that we're able to
add at much lower doses so we're adding
this at one micromolar compared to 30
micromolar
and see even further boosts of
the hdr rates
um one other um
piece of work that we've really focused
on is um
defining a rule set to generate the
highest rates of hdr
and building this into our hdr design
tool and
and this work here um was done
by molly schubert in our lab and is is
um out for review right now but where
we've um
developed um an empirically defined rule
set for where to place silent mutations
so if you're adding an hdr event in a
place that doesn't disrupt the
protospacer
we have found that adding in silent
mutations can really
boost the levels of hdr
and so to show us an example here
in the top um kind of grid
figure that shows that the different
red and blue boxes what we've looked at
many different sizes of insertions and
deletions
and if we um do not put a silent
mutation in
the total level level level of hdr and
this um example at the
very top that saa 1 is coming out at 0.6
percent
of that insertion of that t right there
and then this is shown through
conditional formatting but where we make
the silent mutation
the the blue coloring is where we're
getting higher rates of hdr
so we've done this for as i said for
many different types of hdr events that
we want to create and have developed
a rule set that we have integrated into
our hdr design tool and
a nice summary of that is in the bottom
right corner where we're looking at
different types of hdr events without
silent mutations and the boost you get
with adding silent mutations
and so uh as i mentioned that's all
included in this hdr design tool which
um it took was a lot of work between our
our bioinformatics team and our what
bench scientists
to develop this but it's a novel
bioinformatics tool for single-stranded
hdr template design that
also interfaces with our guide rna
selection tool so you're able to
indicate where you want to make a
correction um
and this will add on add in silent
mutations if that's what you choose the
support this is supported with wild type
cast 9 as well as a knick ace and um
well then comes can be ordered with with
our altar modified donor
oligos that also are modified to further
boost activity
and so we you know we've spent a lot of
time really focusing
uh over the last couple years of
developing rules and reagents to
increase the rates of
hdr for shorter knock-ins but
now we are also spending um
a lot of putting a lot of effort into
how can we
further improve large knock-ins and so
um
one thing we're focusing on right now is
coming up with solutions to reduce blunt
integration if we want to use
double-stranded donor templates and so
this blend integration after you make a
double-stranded template
um there is risk of through
on the non-holographic and joining
pathway those homology arms essentially
being
put into your double-stranded break and
to to avoid that what we've been
studying is using modified don't
double-stranded donor templates um
similar to work that
has been published um expanding the
modifications that we're looking at and
what what we're showing here
is that looking at 300 base pair
insertions
uh a 500 base pair insertion or a
thousand base pair insertion and
comparing
an unmodified double-stranded donor
template
to our ultar one modified template or
altar for two different types of
modifications that we're studying right
now
and we're measuring hdr insertion rates
via min ion in this case and we've got
100 base
pair homology arms on each side we've
delivered these as rnp
complexes and the um figure here
is showing in the solid bar portion
the hdr rates and in the striped portion
the blunt
insertion that we're seeing from those
unmodified templates and so you can see
at
all insertion sizes we have
reduced that blunt integration rate by
using these modified donor templates
and we are continuing to to study this
and this is something
we're really excited about and uh
coupling together
this new hdr enhancer i just talked
about with these modified donor
templates
we show here the the additive effect you
can get
of these two improvements where in blue
is a modified donor template for a um
again 300 500
or a thousand base pair insert and
compared to in blue with no hdr enhancer
added whereas in gray we've
added the hdr enhancer so we've used a
modified double stranded donor template
with our
hdr enhancer our new version and in this
case we are seeing up to
60 hdr rates for this uh
these large insertions
so the um the last thing i want to focus
on here
is our analysis tool that we've
developed and specifically focus
on how we analyze our crispr editing
events
through using our ramp seek technology
so as i mentioned and has been well
published gene editing is not
perfect uh crispr can result in edits
at unintended places in the genome
and so we need a way to to measure these
on target as well as these off-target
effect
events um be able to identify and
quantify them so i want to talk through
the workflow
that we use in our lab for detecting
and quantifying off-target editing
events
so so an example workflow that we go
through
is first to nominate the off target
sites
and this can be done through different
methodologies
through guide seek through an in-silico
prediction tool through other in vitro
assays
but once you get a nominated list of
sites that are predicted or have been
um empirically defined through a guide
seek
type technology we then make a
a panel using our rampsync technology to
then
do amplicon sequencing and quantify in
your cell type
in high throughput the actual level of
editing and then we have a data analysis
pipeline that we use to um accurately
actually accurately quantify those
levels of editing so to break that down
a little more
um the first thing that we need to do is
identify the off target sites for a
particular guide that we're looking at
and so as i mentioned there you know
there are unbiased detection methods
that you can use there are many
different
silicone prediction methods um the
commonly used guide seek technology out
of the
2015 publication you'll get a readout
like this
which using your guide rna of of
interest will show you
other areas where that double-stranded
tag has been integrated
so we take a combination of these
unbiased detection methods
within silico prediction methods and we
um come up with a list that we then
use the ramp seek system to quantify um
these off target sites
so a little back but a bit of background
about about what ramp seek is
um rh pcr is something we've studied at
idt
for many many years um even decades
and and what this is is it is a
a prime a pcr primer that contains an
rna base which is shown
in blue here and contains a blocking
group
and so what the way this works here is
then our pcr
contains tac polymerase as any amplicon
based
pcr would but it also has rna sh2 and
what rna sh2 does is it recognizes this
this rna base and cleaves 5 prime of it
leaving a hydroxyl group for application
to then
um a three prime oh for application to
then take place
and um this is able to then create very
specific
uh pcr and so um
so we're able to leverage this and do
a very specific pcr do multiplex pcr
and so uh to highlight the technology
um greatest is to reference you to the
the 2011
um publication that came out of our
group but the schematic here
shows nicely how this pcr works where
we've got our
primers that will anneal to your target
and they've got the rna base
and a blocking group and that rnase h2
recognizes
that dna rna hybrid and will then
cleave and hybridize the primers
allowing dna polymerase to extend
the the unblocked unblocked primers
so as i mentioned what this allows you
to do is have
really great specificity and um a much
lower potential for primer dimers and so
that's um
depicted here in this graph um or in
this
gel image on the right where
you can see in when using 10 nanograms
of genomic dna here um
the amount of primer dimers you're
seeing in that bottom band
with standard primers on the left or
when using
the two uh lanes on the right how you're
not detecting those primer dimers when
you're using the rh pcr primers
so what this allows you to do is to have
much higher multiplexing capabilities
where we're able to put up to 5000
uh assays into one panel and do one
reaction
so it's really amenable to to study in a
lot of different
target loci at once
so we've specifically integrated this
ramp seek technology into an ngs
solution
that we are now using for crispr editing
and so so what this what this all comes
with
is an optimized primer design tool so
we've um our bioinformatics team has
worked to make
a a nice user interface where you can
order
and have your pcr primers designed with
those ramps with this rh pcr technology
by simply entering your bed coordinates
um
and then you you get your primer designs
for
for your on target site for up to a 5
000 off target sites
we've developed a high throughput
library prep workflow
um which is depicted below which um you
you have your edited genomic dna and
then your pool of primers
and that red circle in those pools kind
of
indicates that these are blocked primers
and so you do two rounds of pcr
for this um amplicon sequencing and so
the first round is
locus specific pcr where the rna sh2 is
present so this will
um allow you to to target many many
regions at once and not have the risk of
the primer dimers
pcr two is then doing your your
universal amplification adding on those
adapters and then these are sequence
ready to go for illumina sequencing and
then we have um
we have taken our internally developed
analysis pipeline and we are working now
with a third party to make this
available through a cloud-hosted
environment
so as i mentioned our our ramp seek
we have a ramp seek design pool design
tool
that um will support many different
reference genomes
you come with a bed a bed file and then
you can input this in
and you'll get designs for your up to
5000 assays
we'll let you know how many of these can
be pooled together
in what size panels and then showing um
some sequencing data here by using this
technology we're able to get very high
quality sequencing data and
looking at metrics um here as far as
percent mapped reads on target rates and
coverage uniformity for different panel
sizes
when we're using 10 or 50 nanograms of
in this case corial genomic dna samples
the
the set of bars on the far left of each
graph is a is a 19 plex
um assay panel so we've got 19 different
assays in that pool doing
just one pcr reaction the second
plot or second set of bars is for a 282
plex
and then a 994 plex using our high
throughput
protocol or our regular protocol and the
high throughput allows you to only have
to do one spry cleanup
um but you can see here you know great
levels of
uniformity and on target rate
so this is really really great and
allows you to
um do your library prep
in high throughput and so just to kind
of highlight back to that figure that i
showed when where we were developing the
hifi protein
so the figure that went into that
publication
used the ramp seek technology so in this
case we are using this technology to
validate
our high fidelity cast nine and so
that panel on the left where we see many
many off-target
sites you know those were all nominated
through
through guideseek and then we came back
and quantified this with ramp seek
so in this case we're looking at um in
all of the different
conditions we tried we are looking at
essentially over 1500 different
individual pcr reactions that we're able
to greatly reduce
by running these panels of assays
together
and so this is just really great for
reducing reagents reducing time and
able to produce great validation data
for um
for this high fidelity protein and the
ram seek technology
now has been published in um in many
different
journals now and this highlights on some
of the different publications where
people have used this technology to
assess their off target editing
um rampsy can also be really really
useful
for genomic screens or or large
knockout studies that you're doing um
because the ramp seek
design tool can do all of the pcr design
for you
you then do your delivery your library
prep
and you can do your data analysis and in
this case you know we used
that for when we were validating the
cast 12a ultra protein so we're looking
at
120 different sites and droquette cells
and 96 different sites and 293 cells
and trying to see at these different pam
sites how
much better ultra has gotten and we um
have done this all through our
ramp seek ngs analysis design library
prep
and our and our internal analysis tool
and so
um to mention that that
analysis tool um and kind of bring us
back to the workflow so again the first
piece is to to identify your off target
sites
and then to do your quantification
through a ramp seek ngs amplicon
sequencing
and then now to analyze that data um
we've built a tool that we refer to as
crisp alterations
and are pertinent partnering with a
third party to build this user interface
where you're able to simply do a drag
and drop
of your fastq files into this and get
your target report readouts your
analysis
through visualizations and uh
to highlight um how all the back end of
that
is working and what we're doing here is
um the pipeline is doing the sequencing
qc it's doing the adapter trimming
the quality filtering the reed merging
we're doing
the filtering and the binning and the
target alignment
and then what comes out here is then you
can kind of see some
some representations of this on the
right visualizations of your indel
profiles this is compatible with igb
this will show you perfect hdr so this
is um
been incredibly useful and this will um
we are working to get this um put out in
the cloud
and be be provided for you with uh
with ram seek and so um
to show some functional data of our
internal pipeline
what we've done here is um we are
using a synthetic data set where we know
the the editing is 50
um of a lot of different target types
we've looked at 603
um different target spaces right here
and we are comparing um what our tool
predicts
as the editing knowing the truth is 50
so in green on the far right of the
graph shown here on the left side of the
slide is for cas9 if we focus on that
is the crisp alterations tool compared
to some other
tools that we've tried out there and
just the high accuracy we're getting
from
this analysis pipeline for both cast 9
as well as cast 12a
which is shown on the um
right hand side of the slide so with
that
i i really want to thank the fantastic
functional genomics team at rnp at idt
that has done all of this great
innovation work to
really try to um improve every step of
the way of of the crispr workflow and
and keep coming up with
innovative technologies for this so with
that
um thank you for your attention and i'm
happy to take any questions
all righty awesome job well we're all
set so pretty much from here i'll just
do some quick editing on the front and
back ends
and then since there's no interruptions
during your presentation we don't need
to do any editing there
and then i will have it ready for the
event next week and also sunday
link
okay sounds great awesome any questions
for me before we wrap up
i don't think so okay sounds good well
if anything comes up feel free to reach
out if not i will send that link over
once it's ready
okay sounds good alrighty have a great
weekend bye